hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast
whistleblower we just escaped our friend
Chris Walker and I'm pretty sure we're
gonna run right into him again but now
we're gonna move forward in this
delightfully delectable game hello it is
the guy it's the priest from the first
game or the another first game but I
mean you know what I mean oh my god you
look so much better after what happened
to you in the future but my past oh good
for you if you don't know what happened
to him you got to go check out my
playthrough the original poopy head
would have to be something to be polkas
you I didn't mean to
God why is everyone being so mean to me
I'm not even human
I haven't looked at myself in the mirror
lately so maybe I'm not
maybe that's all twist to this I am
turning psycho bonkers crazy and I am
becoming one of you this place actually
looks familiar I think this is a part of
the first game I mean the whole place is
a part of the first game but this is
actually a familiar area of the first
game that I've seen before okay so since
I can't go that way I guess I'll go this
way oh maybe that's how that was
originally blocked off in the first game
and that's how this is like a Jesus hi
Chris I knew you were gonna come back I
just didn't know it'd be that sowed
dodge dodge hello how do I that's how I
do that okay okay that was a dead end
what do we do Oh what happened what what
excuse me pardon me looks a bit of a
jump cut there and I didn't do it I'm
known for my jump cuts but I did not do
that okay so I'm back outside again
still can't see a damn thing but
hopefully I can get somewhere all right
although I highly doubt that I'll be
able to escape again No
ghosts in the wood ghosts in the woods
dead people on the ground are those
bones no pieces of trash okay okay this
is delightful I like this it's so
cheerful and sunny all the time how you
here ho
what are you here not exactly talkative
a kind of a semi silent protagonist
antagonist Mikael flies oh good that's
sewer I always wanted it's finally here
Oh am I gonna be Chris in the sewer
again those are my favorite parts of the
Oh No whoa okay some kind of [ __ ] went
down over there I guess I'm gonna have
to turn into an electrician try to solve
that I don't think I want to what
hello someone sounds like they're in
pain but where anybody what happened
god damn sousaphone er Oh kill us burn
the building worse than death here kill
us kill us okay so I need to burn down
the building seems easy enough
how do I get to do that or maybe I don't
actually need to burn down the building
maybe that's just like some guy asking
for help I'm willing to bet that
touching that door would probably kill
me dead so let's not do that so big
electricity problem
wait can I get to that that one says
okay that was probably a warning I
should heed so where else can I go I
guess I can go through here can I burn
down the building desks way can't what
pardon what the hell is going on over
here okay so yeah yeah
no yeah god it's so confusing I think
I'm going in a circle but really I'm
going a new way all right
[Music]
oh stop that
oh you stop that right now oh you sick
bastard
stop it Oh God Oh get a room man I guess
you have a roomie at this basement all
to yourself Excel oh oh oh
not cool not cool need to change the
batteries I'm not even gonna describe
what happen if you didn't understand
okay Joker let me Batman could come stop
you so I gotta go back down into the
place I was just there mr. laughy he's
gonna come over there and get a fist to
the face hey how's it going chuckles oh
come on
shut up man no no no no no no no you son
of a [ __ ] I knew something like that
was gonna happen
you ass bag McGee no go to hell
there's that string quartet one or mr.
sousaphone man is
yeah they're come on go through here get
through not there I didn't think you
were still here god damn it oh you
bastard ass no God no win-win-win woman
sucking ass no no no I didn't think he
was still there I didn't think it was
still alive God what the hell cave are
you kidding me
that's where you start me you son of a
[ __ ]
dad gone no okay this time I need to
always just open the door he's not a
[ __ ] no no no no no you still there
you still there you there yet let's go
oh man there's closed it should be good
for a little bit you see him run away a
bit more he is not dumb he just opens
the door he doesn't get on the floor oh
god oh god oh god don't know why I came
down here okay
I was assuming I was this gonna be a way
for him to kill me the son of a [ __ ] I
think the game may be no walrider
walrider coming through there I think
the game made that hallway so that if
you die and go back and get the second
jump scare the douches anyway I don't
think I need this okay all right take
two going through on my way to wherever
the hell I'm trying to go where am I
trying to go by the way what the hell is
that supposed to be there's like world
war two bunkers on the ground over here
and as opposed to this being a normal
insane asylum this is like custom-built
[ __ ] into the map it's crazy and I
love it don't get me wrong I really like
it but I mean whoever designed this
place most of it just crazy Essene habit
no one of us has amnesia you stay the
hell out of my life you stay out there
Oh son of a basket case let it go this
way I really did think that god I had
every flashback to an amnesia mount
water monster moment like the very first
one what is crying in the night do I
even want to know okay
house good one thank you for constantly
treating my oh my god what is this
look at this custom-built [ __ ] oh my
god
like who designed this who designed this
to be exactly what a horror movie should
be don't get me wrong I love it but Olli
out okay all right okay all right I'm
with it I'm hip I can dig it
ah with it I want to see more I want
more scarce bring it on
you haven't even scratched the surface
of what I can handle my body can handle
the greatest of scares I bet I'm gonna
look in the mirror in my faces can be
totally messed up because I think that's
what this oh that is pretty
I didn't even know this oh it was up in
the mountains because in the first game
he drove way up God dang it this place
is huge okay I did not realize this
place was this freakin big oh my god
climbing on the rooftops Rises Mary
Poppins yeah get it get it I'm tough I'm
an IT guy but I got muscle oh no no no I
wanna be
Wow yeah I probably broke like all of my
ribs I wanted to be singing with Mary
Poppins on the London roof oh oh no I
cannot be okay after that and I'm okay
[Music]
Tim a tiny tiny box Timmy there you
sound different
what's going on they have kids here so
I'm trying to get that what I'm
understanding okay um where am I
supposed to go this way all right
I don't go towards Timmy cuz that would
it be bad
he just likes to hear himself to bear on
our gender a small piece of fish
he'll hurt us don't Shinshin pulling a
mad dog here okay so that's weird why
why would you do that Wow if you have
any idea what they're talking about it's
uh not good not good what they're
talking about doing to me when they find
me all right then
god this amazed little piggy oh no don't
touch
time okay okay
ah Timmy you got you got a creepier
that's what you got I see a lot of your
big box brothers over here you're all
having a conversation without they all
having a grand old time with a baby hi
hi hi hi oh you're dead okay okay what
did I just write if I die oh no oh no oh
oh oh wait this is the first note camera
put these through these real quick you
can pause the game and read these if you
want cuz I don't have time to read
through all of them but you can flip
through them to read them okay dah dah
dah dah dah dah animals kitchen oh wait
no it's going backwards sorry sorry this
is going from front to back
um whoa yeah oh my goodness oh my god
this is so oh no I know God what the
hell I don't know I don't know what to
order those are going in for geez god I
thought that face is looking at me
okay okay no thank you
still in here with the boys just have a
fun time it's really cool that you pause
there
okay cool so uh which man a cannibal
cannibal Sam Frank
dank blank pink no no no god just stop
jumping me
god it's been constant jump scares Danny
wants to die how I'm just trying to
survive man don't mess with me I'm a man
on the edge I don't know what I'm doing
oh man here we go
oh yeah I conducted another interview
with your patient Dennis this afternoon
have to agree with your suspicions in
the course of a 40-minute interview I
had wide exposure to all four of
Dennis's expressed personalities as near
as I could tell two brothers their
father and their grandfather they seemed
primarily concerned with some sort of
life-threatening flood though there was
little consistency between this event
having already happened or threatening
and meeting an imminent arrival the
clarity of his delusion and performative
nature of the personalities expression
is certainly suggests mental malingering
I admittedly fallen the first Stenberg
camp of categorical skepticism of
dissociative personality disorder but
Dennis's case seems clearly invented by
an attention-seeking patient more likely
symptom of gross narcissism intimacy
physic obsessive compulsive disorder
continuous shock therapy good sincerely
dr. Wolfram Wolfram the inventor of that
thing that made all that cool thing that
helped me get through college push the
thing
there we go okay I'm still inside the
walls
you guys gotta do anything about it guys
gonna slaughter me like a goat okay okay
over over over it's one guy that's the
guy that's one guy oh my god why didn't
I make that connection first Jesus I
thought I literally thought there were
more than one character there it was the
same guy that came up and said that
there were bad things down stair it's
all the same guy oh my god that's crazy
literally but also really cool people if
I didn't get that why didn't I get that
okay I'm almost out of batteries here
jeez I do not have enough to get through
all this now which way do I go
so freakin amazed that I can't see here
here over here what do you think hi
oh no it's not the same guy okay okay
okay crazy crazy psycho going around the
corner gonna get away from you
okay where where where oh here god damn
it
oh no no no no oh no no no no no under
other god damn oh I didn't ever think
about under I was too concerned with
over that I never even thought about
under over
ah come on where the hell am I supposed
to go maybe just jump oh just go up
never mind sorry I'm an idiot I'm a
little frazzled right now don't know
what I'm doing go go go
down downtown off and off and off we go
go go
alright so that's okay the
multiple-personality guy up there see
it's gonna have fun on zone and then I
don't have to worry about it anymore
whoa oh my god Oh oh goodness gravy holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that is a big mosaic
blur for you but holy Frick of frack I
am out good golly oh my god that was the
most disturbing thing I've seen in a
game holy crap this game was definitely
pushing me literal insanity holy crap
Oh God that was horrifying
okay I'm gonna end it there cuz it's a
nice stopping point but Jesus you have
just be ward you have to play the game
if you want to see that or you have to
go to another person's playthrough if
you want to see that it was bad it was
really really bad so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done as always I will see you in the
next video
bye-bye
you